Glenn Greenwald Glenn Greenwald who is a
lefty I know he goes on Tucker a lot now
people think he's a crazy right winger
but he's a lefty he went on Tucker to
discuss what's going on with with this
level of strange coordination that seems
to be happening between big government
and big Tech
how did Jim Baker from the FBI wind up
the general counsel of Twitter a lot of
lawyers in this country a lot of capable
lawyers but you hire the FBI lawyer at
the center of russiagate I mean that
seems like a means of control by a
government agency over a social media
company to me
the tentacles of the U.S Security State
are in almost every single institution
of authority and Power in this country I
still find it mind-boggling how it used
to be controversial the CIA would have
programs to clandestinely influence news
outlets okay so they obviously continued
on that but you I just wanted to play
that small snippet because this is
really incredible stuff an FBI lawyer
was working at Twitter do you really
understand that and then was vetting the
releases as they came out God bless Elon
Musk the second he found out about it he
fires the guy but this is crazy crazy
stuff and what I really think look the
hunter Biden laptop stuff I don't care
about Hunter Biden smoking crack on a
webcam or banging hookers or whatever
snorting cocaine off the floor when
looking for cheese or whatever he said
he was doing I don't care about that
stuff that much like that's people have
addictions people have people do all
sorts of things like I'm libertarian
mostly when it comes to drugs although I
don't think it should be smoked crack
however his business dealings emails to
his father about money going to the big
man and how did he get this crazy job at
barisma a guy who was a crackhead who
had no experience in the energy sector
like these are things that are important
the fact that Jim Baker at Twitter was
basically implying like oh we don't know
if this was hacked or not when there was
no evidence that it was hacked right
from beat one everybody was saying that
Hunter dropped the laptop off at the
repair shop that's what the repair shop
owner said that's what Rudy Giuliani who
eventually got the laptop said and of
course the FBI starts looking into Rudy
so there's something really really nuts
here and what I think this really leads
to beyond the corruption related to
barisma and Ukraine and not to say
that's not important because we're in
this war not war with Ukraine and it
feels like these things are somewhat
connected and there's some weird money
laundering thing going on there okay
fine to me the the much bigger fish in
this thing is what did the government do
related to covid when there were those
of us who were saying maybe this was a
lab link or there were those of us that
that we're saying that vaccine mandates
were coming or that vaccines don't work
as promised or maybe that we should have
more clinical trials or maybe that you
shouldn't kick kids out of school and
lock people down and there's going to be
second order effects and all of that
stuff if the government was stepping on
our Free Speech related to that well
then there's something really
um it's deeply important and it's deeply
important because if we don't figure out
what happened
if we don't realize that boy there were
some people that were right about some
things and they were treated really
horribly and people who were horrible
about things and wrong about things were
treated really well we'll never get to
reconcile what happened and maybe maybe
that's what the system wants right it
wants this endless nonsensical time
release truth situation where everyone
will eventually get tired of saying the
truth because you won't get any credit
for it right you you will be treated
like a freak for it